present job Theodore von Hopi boys are
doing well down there in Southern
California it's Alex coming from you up
here in the Sacramento Valley okay
Curtis boarding supplies with this
coronavirus went to Costco got some
light supplies didn't want a Ford I
thought it'd be rude for the older
people and younger people what are you
guys doing are you guys hoarding
supplies light supplies going out every
day getting what you need let us know
love you guys buzz buzz young love you
too beautiful great yeah guy probably
does [ __ ] drag [ __ ] too you know they
could drag queens skin right oh wait
that dude is way hotter than my my
girlfriend junior high school girlfriend
my junior high school girlfriend was
really tough oh yeah she used to pick me
up and give me a [ __ ] kiss and stuff
after school
huh pick you up and kiss you yeah so you
pick me up in all the other kids with
seat on the bus and they came by and
there was nothing I could do bro she was
so much bigger than me she would pick me
up and wrap my legs around her hell you
kiss me it was so [ __ ] rough but she
was all right look Jamie Lee Curtis have
a dick no they said she was born or
never night after that
yeah did she have a nub I don't think so
I saw her True Lies I've seen her person
she's a beautiful thing yeah okay what's
this guy sent hoarding what do you guys
do I'm not I mean I load up on some
stuff so I'm straight with the kiddos
but I'm not hoarding like I went to go
buy meat you know cuz I'm in that weird
diet that carnivore diet you're always
on something yeah always dude when you
just go live your life yeah I'm living
brother oh but I would I shop stop oh my
god I'm on my deathbed and the lady in
front of me tried buying all the meat
all the meat at this market at this
butcher and the dude was like this ain't
happening look at all those people
behind you think you know selfish a dish
she just got to look out for my knees
like ain't how it matter if I get out of
here really and she but she only got
three pounds of meat and that's it now
that's what they should do three pounds
of meat I think it's very good at the
butcher he's like healing
three pounds three pounds and three
pieces of meat or some [ __ ] like that
it's cuba baby
welcome to Cuba I know you know they say
the economy's tanking because of all but
not for everybody yeah I think about the
CEO of Charmin then what [ __ ] buying
islands everywhere oh and also I notice
they put toilet paper then cotton balls
when the toilet paper is out and then
q-tips or people wiping their asses you
know I was shocked when I first found
out about the toilet paper thing I went
to Costco and I had no idea this is
right at the beginning I didn't know
about the toilet paper frenzy but I
didn't even think about it
we get to Costco I'm thinking [ __ ]
there's not gonna be any food it's gonna
be [ __ ] empty we walk in and there's
a sign no water no toilet paper and you
know you know of course no water makes
sense you're stranded in a desert you're
[ __ ] all you're thinking about is
water you ain't thinking about [ __ ] you
ain't even thinking about your kids
you're thinking about your [ __ ] water
right that makes sense
food some kind of food should be number
two yeah you know what I mean toilet
paper should be like 23rd right you know
what I mean yes but it was [ __ ]
second and that crazy so straight like I
was like how important sense wait am I
gonna make us jump in the shower I know
I won't jump with the shower
they're not gonna brainwash me into
jumping in the shower and cleaning my
ass we're gonna figure this out my boy
come on this propaganda my boy counter
washes ass in the sink I seen in
restaurants I take a [ __ ] why jumps on
the sink and washes his ass like a sick
bird dude yeah they used to take wash
your hand and I was young they would say
wipe your hand with your ass I've washed
your hand in the sink Wow yeah we're out
of toilet
oh is that Louisiana that's how they did
there I mean I just think if you didn't
have any toilet paper you so you reach
in and just scoop it out and then go
wash your hands and then at some point
your ass if your hand right your hands a
straight-a student that's why Katrina
I was a B student down I see D student
CD I'm party but no you wouldn't smell
your hand bro on you would [ __ ] wipe
your ass yeah then wash your head and
just go now Norma's now hi everybody
would stink and like radioactive and
chip that's it ever Sabinas you you guys
look too far into things man you guys
are still smelling the [ __ ] move on
that's why god that's why I got hit you
a tree what do you got hey guys no
Walker yeah get your hand those levees
[ __ ] snap what do you think here Jim
what are you guys doing y'all [ __ ] in
your hand over there what do you guys
know who's Asian just squat on the
sidewalk and drop deuces oh they got the
best squats you see I'm hanging out got
squat down low I bet the [ __ ] just
[ __ ] flows out yeah you know and how
golden like in these times how golden
are perfect shits these days right Wow I
know those shits will you [ __ ]
and you wipe your ass and no [ __ ] oh oh
oh he's in for that I always know Crona
or not but right now that's more
important than ever than perfect shits
make believe in God it's where you get
to it you got to relax and take deep
breaths and and you got it's hard not to
clench that but don't cut it off it's
it's hard so you got it you got to
figure out how to just get into that
zone and just breathe jets are huge the
other takes like a two-foot [ __ ] it just
keeps going oh yeah you want to like cut
it off but you're like yeah but do you
think it knows but then you got to think
you just got to focus you got to think
Corona
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]